just grateful for the opportunity to
play with the guys that I did have the
opportunity to play with and it's been
like that every year that I've played in
the league so we had enough next year we
will have enough and we're going to be
right back in the same situation and uh
we're gonna get it done hey the Miami
Heat the lowest scoring team in the
league
and the last team to make it into the
Eastern Conference playoffs they lost
only after they had won three straight
games to start this series so it was a
game seven they stand eye to eye with
history and they did not blink the heat
are going to the NBA finals
what a win on the road third win in this
series
for the heat in Miami
late in this late in our telecast
tonight in the fourth quarter they
replayed a clip from last year after the
Eastern Conference Finals when you said
a year from now we're going to be back
we're going to be in the same position
and we're going to get it done how did
you know that I have so much belief in
myself and this group of guys
um in the squad that uh coach Pat and
SPO and everybody else put together I
see it every single day I know how good
of players that we have I know how good
of a team we are and we made it happen